mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président et nous poursuivons notre
cycle d'audition
audition consacrée à l'avenir des
concessions autoroutières en accueillant
Monsieur Philippe Nouri président
d'autoroute par erreur
qui sont des filiales des phases qui
entretient exploit 2323 km d'autoroute
en France
l'exploitation de ces autoroutes
arrivera échéances en 2035 pour apr et
2036 pourra rire à titreliminaire je me
permets de rappeler que notre commission
souhaite à travers ce cycle d'audition
que nous avons débuté la semaine
dernière anticiper la fin des contrats
de concession autoroutier et à faire en
sorte que le bilan les concessions
telles qu'elles ont été pensées et mises
en œuvre jusqu'à présent
dans cette perspective je souhaiterais
vous interroger sur les mêmes points que
c'est évoqué que Monsieur Pierre Copé et
Arnaud Kemar la semaine dernière ma
première question est de nature plutôt
prospective comment appréhendez-vous la
fin des contrats de concession comment
l'anticipez-vous je souhaiterais en
particulier savoir dans quelle mesure et
comment vous préparer et vous préparer à
la restitution des biens ou en son les
inventaires des biens de retour à la
définition du doctrine quant au bon état
cible de ses biens la seconde question
porte cela ne vous étonnera pas sans
doute sur la rentabilité des concessions
sujette à de nombreux commentaires
plusieurs rapports récents notamment
celui de l'Inspection Générale des
Finances qui a récemment fuité dans la
presse tendant à démontrer que certaines
SCA ont des taux de rentabilité bien
supérieur à ce qui était prévu par les
contrats de concession
certains suggèrent d'étudier
l'opportunité de raccourcir la durée de
certains contrats le ministre Bruno Le
Maire a indiqué et avoir saisi le
Conseil d'État de cette question que
répondez-vous à de tels discours et
propositions j'en viens à ma troisième
question qui porte quant à elle sur la
fiscalité des autoroutes la première
ministre a évoqué l'idée est de faire
davantage contribuer le secteur
autoroutier au plan d'avenir pour les
transports notamment en faveur du monde
ferroviaire quel regard portez-vous sur
cette proposition je rappelle que les
sociétés d'autoroute remettent en cause
depuis 2021 le versement de la
contribution volontaire exceptionnelle à
l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures lafites compte tenu de
l'indexation de la taxe d'aménagement du
territoire sur l'inflation faut-il
s'attendre à une réaction similaire si
d'éventuelles les nouvelles taxes
étaient prévues des discussions avec le
gouvernement ont-elles déjà été engagées
sur ce point
pouvez-vous évoquer quels moyens sont
consacrés à la décarbonation des
autoroutes avez-vous estimé les besoins
totaux en la matière enfin je viens à
une question que nous avons abordé la
semaine dernière est relative à l'avenir
des péages autoroutiers
consubstantielles à la fin des
concessions autoroutières comment après
avoir rendez-vous cette problématique
avant de vous céder la parole pour une
durée de 10 minutes au maximum je
précise que nous en fait le choix
d'entendre un grand nombre d'acteurs ce
qui pour pour conséquence de limiter la
durée maximale à 1h15 pour chacune des
auditions de notre manie de notre
matinée je voudrais je vous demanderai
monsieur présent donc de respecter ce
temps de parole car de la même manière
et en plein accord avec les chefs de fil
de des groupes nous avons convenu qu'un
seul orateur par groupe politique
interviendrait et qu'il disposerait de 4
minutes pour le groupe les républicains
socialiste écologique et républicain et
3 minutes pour les autres groupes hormis
le groupe Union centriste et tant
entendu que j'introduis chacune de ces
au ditions je vous remercie monsieur le
Président et je vous souhaite la parole
merci monsieur
dans la mesure où les tous les risques
sont transférés au concessionnaire on
entend régulièrement que la concession
autoroutière et serait une rente une
activité de rente et je crois que cela
ne correspond pas du tout à la réalité
car elle est par nature une activité à
risque
des risques au trafic au financement à
la construction voire même à l'entretien
du réseau alors quelques mots peut-être
pour illustrer le risque trafic avec la
crise économique de
2008-2009 juste après la privatisation
le trafic poid lourd avait chuté de près
de 20% sur 2 ans et il a fallu attendre
plus de 10 ans pour retrouver le niveau
de 2007 je rappelle aussi la crise des
gilets jaunes en 2018 2019 qui a eu un
impact important aussi sur nos trafic
sans oublier bien sûr la crise sanitaire
covid en 2020 et 2021 qui a entraîné un
effondrement de notre trafic
puisqu'il a chuté de près de 25% entre
2019 et 2020
j'en profite pour vous dire que nous
sommes bien loin du plan d'affaires
établi par nos actionnaires au moment de
la privatisation dans le cadre de
l'appel d'Off de la privatisation en ce
qui concerne le trafic et le chiffre
d'affaires je crois que c'est important
de le dire dans cette période où on
entend et on dit on lit tellement de
contre vérité sur une supposée sur
rentabilité
autre intérêt pour être intérêt pour la
pour l'État nous apportons je pense que
vous le savez toutes et tous une forte
contribution fiscale
qui sait par exemple dans le grand
public que l'État est le premier
bénéficiaire des revenus de péage avec
un peu plus de 40% du montant qui lui
revient au travers de la fiscalité
générale TVA et impôt sur les sociétés
et au travers de la fiscalité spécifique
taxe d'aménagement du territoire et
redevance de Manial qui sait que nos
finançons toujours et encore les autres
modes de transport au travers de la
taxes d'aménagement du territoire et de
l'ordonnance de maniale ce sont près
d'un milliard d'euros qui sont alloués
chaque année au budget de la fuite nous
sommes donc les premiers financeurs de
cette agence qui qui soutient les
projets routiers mais surtout des
projets ferroviaires ou fluviaux
je crois que notre financement
représente plus de 50% des ressources
totales cumulées de la fuite depuis 2005
et au total c'est plus de 5 milliards
d'euros
qui sont versés chaque année par les
concessionnaires autoroutiers au Trésor
public
le modèle permet aussi une grande
capacité d'investissement pour la
modernisation et le développement du
réseau
au profit de la desserte des territoires
vous le savez parfaitement mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous qui êtes
extrêmement proche des territoires
apparaît et area ont investi depuis 2006
plus de 5 milliards d'euros pour le
développement de du réseau nous avons
construit dans cette période cette
nouvelle section d'autoroute nous avons
élargi à trois voies 270 km d'autoroute
nous avons créé ou reconfiguré 17
diffuseurs ou une autoroutier pour
améliorer l'expérience client et
diminuer la congestion et ces 5
milliards d'euros ont aussi permis
d'améliorer l'insertion environnementale
des autoroutes dans le domaine du
traitement des eaux de la protection
anti-bruit et en matière de protection
de la biodiversité avec la construction
d'une vingtaine de passage à faune à
grand gabarit alors je reviendrai
monsieur le Président sur la partie
transition écologique des carbonation
des autoroutes dans la séquence des
questions je voudrais
poursuivre en indiquant que beaucoup
beaucoup de fausses informations
circulent sur nos concessions alors en
partie par non de pédagogie de notre
part mais aussi sans doute parce que le
modèle est très complexe et très
particulier on retrouve même des erreurs
d'analyse dans des rapports officiels
comme celui de l'Autorité de la
concurrence en 2014
l'autorité avait analysé à l'époque la
rentabilité instantanée des concessions
et comme si nous étions une société
industrielle ou commerciale classique et
elle avait elle avait pas vraiment
intégré dans son analyse
le coût d'acquisition des concessions 7
milliards d'euros pour nous les dettes
existantes dans les sociétés
plus de 6 milliards d'euros pour nous et
les engagements à investir qui
figuraient dans les contrats plus d'un
milliard d'euros pour nous et elle avait
aussi sous-estimé le fait que l'actif
sera rendu en bon état d'entretien
gratuitement et totalement désendetté en
fin de concession
la commission d'enquête de votre
assemblée avait produit un travail de
qualité en 2020 et nous partageons
d'ailleurs la grande majorité des
recommandations sauf pour l'étude
financières qui comportait des erreurs
majeures de raisonnement et de
méthodologie alors je pourrais bien sûr
revenir sur ce sujet de la rentabilité
dans la séquence des questions mais
juste un exemple pour illustrer les
erreurs de monsieur Fortin expert en
fusion acquisition d'entreprises à qui
votre collègue le sénateur de la Haye
avait confié l'étude financière des
concessions autoroutières
l'étude provisionne prévisionnelle de
monsieur Fortin elle a été établie sur
nos comptes afin 2019
depuis cette date trois exercices se
sont écoulés 2020 2021 2022 et on peut
voir aujourd'hui que monsieur Fortin
avait très largement surestimé dans sa
prévision les dividendes versées par
rapport à la réalité il les a surestimer
de 2 milliards d'euros sur ces trois ans
donc il les a plus que doublés ce qui
génère avec bien d'autres erreurs un
écart de près de 3% sur le terrier
actionnaire afin 2022 entre son étude et
la réalité je donne à ce stade ce seul
ce seul exemple
tout en reconnaissant les erreurs de
monsieur Fortin et rappelant le
caractère hypothétique de ces calculs le
rapport
IGF c'est aussi intéressant au théories
actionnaires alors ce terrier
actionnaire je pense que maintenant vous
êtes familiarisé avec les deux types de
terribles le thé réactionnaire d'un côté
et le théorie concession ou terrible
projet de l'autre
le théâtre solaire pour nous ce n'est
pas le bon indicateur je pense que c'est
aussi la vie de la RT d'ailleurs
au passage
on peut déplorer que que la RT
autorité indépendante créée par la loi
Macron 2015 ne soit pas systématiquement
placé au centre des débats sur ce sujet
sensible de la rentabilité des
concessions c'est un régulateur
indépendant et rigoureux qui mesure je
pense les enjeux
du modèle autoroutier concessif et qui
est justement chargé entre autres
missions de suivre la rentabilité des
concessions or la RT a justement estimé
à deux reprises en 2019 et en 2022 dans
ces deux rapports sur l'économie
générale des concessions que le Terry
concession était la bonne mesure de la
rentabilité contrairement aux
réactionnée encore une fois qui relève
plus des risques et périls du seul
acteur privé
et c'était réconcession mesurée par la
RT ressortent très proche de ceux
attendus au moment de la privatisation
en se situant à un niveau raisonnable
cette conclusion est d'ailleurs partagée
par par l'IGF mais l'IGF ne conclut pas
pour autant à l'absence de surprofit
car l'IGF tout comme monsieur Fortin a
étudié le Teri actionnaire encore une
fois pour nous ce n'est pas la bonne
référence mais si on veut regarder ce
terrier actionnaire encore faut-il
partir sur de bonnes bases
ce qui n'est pas le cas pour l'IGF je
reviendrai certainement en tout cas vous
l'avez compris je conteste formellement
toute idée de surentabilité ou de
surprofit pour appairer et area comme on
peut le lire ou l'entendre en réalité en
réalité nous sommes très proches des
objectifs qui ont été affichés par nos
actionnaires dans le plan d'affaires qui
a été communiqué à l'État dans le cadre
de l'appel d'offre de privatisation
un petit mot pour terminer Monsieur le
Président sur nos contrats alors ces
contrats c'est vrai qu'ils étaient à
l'origine quasiment les mêmes que ceux
qui existaient lorsque l'État était
concessionnaire et ce sont ces contrats
là qui ont été valorisés par nos
actionnaires en 2005 mais on oublie de
dire que ces contrats ils ont été
sérieusement durcis au fur et à mesure
de nos différents avenants
quelques exemples il y a eu la
suppression du foisonnement vous savez
tous ce que représente le raisonnement
il s'agissait d'augmenter plus les
sections avec beaucoup de trafic pour
accroître artificiellement les recettes
c'est une pratique qui est existait
lorsque l'État était à la fois
concessionnaire et
concessionnaire et actionnaires cette
pratique a été supprimée en 2007 il y a
eu aussi le dursement le durcissement
des différentes pénalités il y a eu la
mise en place
de clauses de restitution des éventuels
avantages indues lorsque les plannings
de travaux se décale dans le temps et il
y a eu aussi en 2015 une clause de
limitation des tarifs en cas de chiffre
d'affaires excédentaire ainsi qu'une
clause qui prévoit la même manière une
fin anticipée mais pour la période
d'extension qui a été octroyée dans le
cadre du plan de relance 2015 en réalité
à chaque négociation d'avenants l'État
en a profité et c'est normal pour
équilibrer les contrats et les mettre à
jour c'est en quelque sorte une une
forme de de recalage périodique qui a eu
lieu tous les 4 à 5 ans
par ailleurs le supposé laxisme de
l'État à notre rencontre c'est une
contre-vérité je l'ai entendu à dans
certaines des auditions que vous avez eu
ces derniers temps
à partir de la privatisation je dois
vous dire qu'il y a eu un changement
rapide et profond dans les relations
entre l'État qui n'étaient plus à la
fois actionnaires et concessionnaire et
les concessionnaires privés
les contrôles ont été très vite
renforcés les négociations dans le cadre
des contrats de plan ou autre plan
d'investissement ont été très vite de
plus en plus après difficiles notamment
sur le plan financier et nous avons
désormais des objectifs de qualité
d'exploitation ambitieux avec des seuils
pénalisables en cas de en cas de
non-respect alors quand j'entends que le
rapport des forces serait déséquilibré
entre l'État et les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute en faveur
des sociétés concessionnelles autoroute
je crois qu'on se trompe d'époque car la
réalité est bien différente depuis bien
longtemps les contrôles sont permanents
et très diversifiés et je dois dire que
les équipes ministérielles sont à la
fois très compétentes et très exigeantes
merci pour ces propos liminaires je vais
donner la parole à Gérard là elle est
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
cette présentation synthétique
d'emblée je vous rassurer je n'ai pas de
dogme
je considère que s'il y a spéculation et
critique aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
essentiellement de votre fête je préfère
le dire ainsi et en même temps je pense
qu'on ne peut pas dire que tout va bien
et qu'il suffit d'attendre je crois que
c'est opportun que nous ayons à nous à
nous pencher sur ce sujet
et moi j'ai une petite question c'est
que nous devrions être dans la phase
préparatoire à la fin des concessions
enfin je pense qu'on va y entrer très
très vite
et dans le même temps nous ne pouvons
pas nous contenter d'attendre seulement
la pleine exécution des contrats car il
y a un certain nombre d'ambitions qui
nous attendent notamment des carbonation
aménagement je ne développe pas ça me
conduit donc à m'interroger
autour de la question suivante
il faut préparer la restitution des
ouvrages mais dans la préparation de la
restitution
je dirais de ces périmètres condés
n'y a-t-il pas lieu finalement de dire
chiche nous sommes prêts on y va et
voilà les défis que nous sommes prêts à
relever ce qui évite peut-être
d'avoir à renégocier des contrats à les
remettre en cause à les reprolonger
enfin bref c'est une question que je me
pose parce que je bon questionnement
gravite autour de l'idée on ne peut pas
atteindre sans rien faire la fin des
concessions en même temps il faut
s'assurer d'être le plus irréprochable
possible et si ça peut être d'utilité
publique ça pourrait vous donner
l'occasion de rebondir sur le sujet
c'est pour questionnements à leur niveau
merci merci je vais donner la parole à
Eric gold
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général votre
audition doit permettre d'en savoir plus
sur les orientations futures en matière
de mode de déplacement sur les
autoroutes et ce qui devrait être prévu
dans les futurs contrats alors on a
beaucoup parlé du développement des
véhicules autonomes et bien entendu
je vais avoir un petit peu le problème
de gorge aussi donc
on a beaucoup parlé du développement des
véhicules autonomes et de la possibilité
de les utiliser sur autoroute
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'on est
un peu moins bavard sur le sujet
j'aimerais avoir votre avis de PDG sur
la circulation future de ce type de
véhicule pour l'instant il n'est pas
possible de confier la conduite à un
véhicule au-delà de 60 km/h pourtant
l'autoroute semble particulièrement se
prêter à la voiture autonome avec des
longs trajets peu d'obstacles et une
vitesse relativement stable il
semblerait même que sa présence
permettrait d'améliorer les conditions
de circulation en absorbant les
perturbations et en forçant le
conducteur adapté une vitesse une bonne
vitesse d'équilibre alors pouvez-vous
m'indiquer quel est aujourd'hui l'état
de la réflexion et quels sont les freins
à la présence du véhicule autonome sur
autoroute sont-ils technologiques
législatif voir psychologique et enfin
faut-il selon vous envisager anticiper
la création de voix spécialement
équipées ou de voies réserver pour ce
type de circulation merci merci chers
collègues la parole est à Pierre mais de
viel
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président
en 2015
le groupe d'études avait noté
la polémique autour du rapport de
l'Autorité de la concurrence et de
Monsieur Lasserre et du cabinet mandanté
par Ségolène Royal microéconomique et
Monsieur Lasserre n'était d'ailleurs
sorti avec une pirouette en indiquant
qu'on lui avait pas posé la bonne
question ce qui expliquait quand même la
qualité médiocre de son rapport qui
calculait on va pas y revenir une
rentabilité à l'instant T et je te
polémique bon on avait j'avais fait la
presse
les concessionnaires avaient été traités
de façon quand même un peu cordiale on
dira et que pensez-vous aujourd'hui
c'est un rapport redondant moi je l'ai
déjà dit que pensez-vous de la qualité
de ce rapport et de ses conclusions
merci la parole est à Jacques Fernique
[Musique]
il y a pas de laxisme le rapport de
force est un privé n'est pas
déséquilibré on se trompe d'époque
moi ce qui me vient en réaction à ce que
vous dites c'est
on se trompe d'époque mais à l'époque
vos prédécesseurs avaient sans doute des
discours du même ordre en disant il n'y
a pas de laxisme les choses sont
rigoureuses je crois que par nature dans
une coopération publique privée les
choses ne sont pas souples ne sont pas
faciles ne sont pas évidentes et et et
si alors aujourd'hui tout le monde admet
il y a pas de souci qu'on a un réseau de
qualité mais on voit bien que sur ce qui
reste à faire pour
terminer correctement les concessions en
cours il y a des points litigieux sur la
définition du bon état les choses sont
pas évidentes
il est normal qu'il y ait de l'exigence
du point de vue de l'intérêt public du
point de vue d'intérêt général et pour
ce qui succédera
au système concessif d'aujourd'hui
je crois que
il est
quasiment uneanime maintenant
aujourd'hui alors j'aimerais votre
opinion là-dessus que personne ne peut
envisager des concessions aussi longues
que ce qui a été fait parce qu'on voit
bien qu'avec des concessions longues
les conditions d'élaboration d'avenants
qui s'imposent sont compliqués
alors la question de la rentabilité donc
il y a les calculs de la commission du
Sénat il y a ceux de l'IGF il y a ceux
de la RT je pense qu'il y a les vôtres
toutes ces différences de calcul c'est
impressionnant quand on voit les les
tableaux par exemple dans le rapport de
l'IGF ça nous montre en tout cas moi
comme parlementaire je dirais débutant
avec deux ans qui a une question de
transparence d'accès aux données de
paramètres d'indicateurs
qu'on voudrait rigoureux et de leur
suivi qu'il faut mettre en place alors
sur les pour l'avenir que le choix donc
à partir de maintenant tout de suite ou
à partir de ce qui succédera pour vous
c'est 2035 2036 je me trompe pas à la
concession actuelle
deux interrogations sur la décarbonation
donc donc c'est un peu le mot valise que
tout le monde place mais qu'est-ce que
concrètement on y met pour assurer la
transition de l'électro mobilité
le rapport du coi parle d'un usage de la
route et de l'autoroute bien sûr qui qui
sera moins celui de l'auto-solisme qui
nécessitera un fret routier plus
efficient ce qui veut dire que
l'objectif c'est pas toujours plus de
trafic mais c'est donc ça posera une
question aussi de rendement pour les
péages sur justement les moyens comment
la route peut financer de façon plus
importante qu'aujourd'hui ça semble de
toute façon nécessaire au report modo
nécessaire de la transition écologique
et puis aussi comment notre réseau
autoroutier dont je disais au début la
qualité peut rester de qualité face à
l'impact fort qu'on mesure pas encore
suffisamment à mon avis aujourd'hui du
réchauffement climatique la
vulnérabilité du réseau de notre de mode
d'usage de ce réseau merci merci la
parole est à Jean-Claude
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général Mesdames et Messieurs
mes chers collègues je souhaite d'abord
insister sur l'importance de ce cycle
d'audition sur l'avenir des concessions
autoroutières que nous poursuivons
aujourd'hui il permet bien sûr notre
commission de mieux appréhender les
enjeux concrets qui se posent à la fin
des contrats de concession autoroutières
et contrairement à ce qui peut être
déclaré dans la presse par certains il
ne s'agit pas ici de redit dont on ne se
lasse pas il s'agit d'un enjeu central
pour l'État notamment dans le contexte
actuel des finances publiques et un
rapport avec l'aménagement du territoire
nos travaux il me semble s'inscrivent en
effet également dans le contexte global
du financement des mobilités en France
notamment du rail du fret et du
développement des modes de transport
mais je répète en cela les mots de notre
président
vous le savez la question de la entre
guillemets sur rentabilité est au centre
des enjeux et de l'actualité néanmoins
il ne s'agit pas ici de débattre ici de
la méthodologie de calcul de rentabilité
mais question et nos travaux vise à
faire le bilan des concessions tels
qu'elles ont été pensées et mises en
œuvre jusqu'à présent l'objectif de
tirer des enseignements des concessions
qui vont s'achever pour rendre les
prochains contrats moins coûteux pour le
contribuer et pour l'État tout en
conservant l'investissement nécessaire à
l'entretien du réseau mais question
porte sur trois enjeux principaux
principaux le premier enjeu et le prix
le prix des autoroutes l'un des
marqueurs les plus visibles pour les
automobilistes et l'augmentation des
trafics des péages avec une hausse de
4,5 et 5,07% en 2023 sur votre réseau le
réseau APRR quelles sont les éléments
qui justifient les augmentations des
tarifs des péages en général et quels
objectifs sont destinés les bénéfices
supplémentaires pouvez -vous nous
indiquer pour le cas de l'année 2023
quels sont les éléments déterminants des
augmentations si les raisons sont
dépendantes du contexte pourquoi les
sociétés concessionnaires
appliquent-elles des hausses
différenciées
n'est-ce pas qui est le plus beau viaduc
d'Europe et de France n'est-ce pas qui a
été mis en service depuis 2004 et qui
déroule son tapis n'est ce pas sur 2,4
km au dessus du viol à 270 m d'altitude
exploitée donc par la compagnie Eiffage
du viaduc la durée de concession de 78
ans et plus longue que celle habituelle
en raison d'un équilibre plus difficile
à atteindre et j'aimerais que vous
leviez une rupeur une rumeur que nous
entendons localement dans la presse sur
ce que vous souhaiteriez peut-être faire
avec ce viaduc du Millau on vous
séparant de des actions enfin voilà faut
que vous pouvez lever cette rumeur que
nous entendons localement je répète bien
localement en tout cas c'est important
pour nous de le savoir
donc par rapport au viaduc bien sûr
quelles sont les enseignements à tirés
de l'exploitation de ce type de
superstructures pour les concessions à
venir concernant la durée mais aussi
l'augmentation du prix du péage je
précise pour nos collègues que si nous
n'avions pas eu ce mode de
fonctionnement pour ce viaduc jamais
l'autoroute 75 ne rejoindrait n'est-ce
pas le Massif Central et la Méditerranée
et je terminerai mon intervention pour
la troisième jeu celui de la transition
écologique comme ça a été évoqué par nos
collègues et quelles sont les
conséquences des transformations du parc
automobiliste sur les concessionnaires
concrètement quels sont les objectifs
d'électrification des réseaux à PRR et
area et comment sont financés ces
investissements et ensuite concernant
les mobilités la décarbonation du trafic
autoroutier et le développement des
mobilité dite verte sont au cœur des
enjeux de transformation faisant du
futur ça a été rappelé par nos collègues
il semble d'ailleurs qu'à pr RR a mis en
place des aides financières pour le
covoiturage en Haute-Savoie je voulais
dire devant Cyril pelvin qui était là
pouvez-vous nous présenter brièvement ce
dispositif son financement et son
élargissement éventuelle je vous
remercie en tout cas pour répondre à nos
questions merci chers collègues la
parole est à Martine filleul merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président de la
mission monsieur le Président vous avez
déjà réagi sur la question de la
surentabilité et mes collègues vous ont
interrogés également à ce propos donc je
ne vais pas revenir sur ce sujet au
combien important pour cependant mais je
voudrais vous demander de bien vouloir
réagir au conclusions de ce rapport au
scénario possible évoqué dans le cadre
de ce rapport à savoir
réduire de 10 ans la durée des contrats
ou éventuellement augmenter et ou
augmenter le prélèvement sur les
bénéfices ou encore baisser les tarifs
des péages
comment
appréciez-vous ces éléments ces scénarii
et comment apprendez-vous surtout cette
demande d'étudier un raccourcissement
des contrats déjà engagés une deuxième
question concerne l'attribut parue dans
Le Monde à l'initiative de mes collègues
socialistes qui appelle à la création
d'un établissement public à caractère
industriel et commercial qui s'appelle
route de France et qui aurait vocation à
gérer l'ensemble du réseau routier
national non concédé auquel s'ajouterait
le réseau Autority autoroutier pardon
concéder une fois les contrats échus ce
projet est une solution pour construire
une autre voie à l'opposition devenue
stérile entre une renationalisation qui
coûte cher et pour suivre un modèle
concessif qui apparaît abusif dès lors
comment votre groupe continuerait-il
repérer la gestion des concessions dans
l'hypothèse ou celle-ci seront non
renouvelées à terme comment vous
engagez-vous à rendre dans un bon état
les concession à l'expiration des
contrastes telles devaient être le cas
ensuite je voulais poser une troisième
question qui concerne un sujet qui m'est
cher à savoir l'électronisme car j'ai
beaucoup d'interrogations sur le flux
libre tel que développé actuellement sur
l'autoroute à 79 j'entends que ce
dispositif innovant assure le papier de
nombreux avantages qui permet selon vos
dires de gagner en fluidité et en
sécurité cependant je constate que de
nombreux usagers sont mécontents et
laisse sur le côté de la route si j'ose
ce bon mot là sur le côté de la route
tous ceux qui ne sont pas à l'aise avec
l'in formatique le numérique et
contribue beaucoup à les laisser soit
revenir avoir des distances importantes
à parcourir dans ce cadre
voilà est-ce que vous avez pensé à des
aménagements de ce dispositif de flux
libre qui cependant est amené à ce
généraliser sur le territoire pour ne
pas laisser de côté ces exclus du
numérique
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à Michel Dagbert et après
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
président d'accusion monsieur le
Président merci
de vos éclaircissements et de votre
propos liminaire auquel j'ai été très
attentif puisque dans votre propos
liminaire je vais venir à ma question
ensuite mais dans votre propos liminaire
vous avez rappelé que à différentes
reprises
par des discussions avec l'État les
concessions avaient été rééquilibrées ce
qui tente à être un aveu de votre part
que à l'origine les concessions étaient
un peu déséquilibrées je ferme la
parenthèse monsieur le Président je
souhaite vous interroger sur la question
de l'entretien des infrastructures qui
auxquelles sont soumis bien sûr les
concessionnaires les sociétés
concessionnaires sont en effet
contractuellement tenu d'effectuer
l'entretien des voies et ouvrages d'art
qui leur sont concédés elles ont ainsi
l'obligation de réaliser certains
volumes de travaux les concessionnaires
doivent investir jusqu'à la fin des
contrats afin de remettre en bon état
les infrastructures or en décembre 2022
l'Autorité de régulation des Transports
a publié un document très critique face
aux pratiques observées lors de la
passation de marché de travaux de
fournitures et de services mais
également lors de la passation des
contrats de sous-cession la RT rappel
l'importance de disposer de règles
claires sur le calcul de la valeur
estimée d'un marché de travaux et sur le
choix de la procédure d'appel d'offres
elle note aussi le taux importants
d'attribution de marchés de travaux aux
sociétés liées capitalistiquement à apr
aéréa ainsi
ont été passés une part importante de
leur marché avec des sociétés du groupe
Eiffage avec un taux d'attribution
supérieur au taux moyen d'attribution
aux sociétés du groupe Eiffage par
l'ensemble des sociétés concessionnaires
elle émet de fait certaines réserves sur
le coup de certaines opérations et
travaux réalisés et beaucoup regrettent
en effet le manque de transparence sur
les coûts et les prix de chacune de ces
opérations pouvez-vous nous donner votre
sentiment et quelques éléments
d'appréciation sur ces différents points
et les mesures correctives qui
pourraient être envisagées je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues monsieur le
Président je vous propose de répondre à
mes collègues merci merci
elles sont très nombreuses je vais
essayer de d'y répondre mais en les
regroupant par par grand thème si vous
l'acceptez je vais peut-être commencer
par le sujet de la décarbonation des
autoroutes qui est un sujet très
important
comme vous le savez le secteur des
transports représente près de 30% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
France et la part des autoroutes est
estimée à 7% et c'est dire effectivement
l'importance de faire mouvement très
vite et très fort sur sur nos autoroutes
concrètement
pour répondre à votre question sur nos
réseaux apparer et area nous avons
engagé cette transition écologique
depuis plusieurs années au travers de
réalisation qui s'articule autour de de
quatre grands axes premier axe le
développement des mobilités partagées
nous avons déjà aujourd'hui
5000 places de parking de covoiturage
proposé à nos clients et nous devrions
attendre les 7000 places à l'échéance
2025 deuxième point nous avons mis en
service la première
voie réservée aux covoiturage en France
sur autoroute à Grenoble sur l'autoroute
A48 en septembre 2020
et troisièmement le plan
d'investissement apparaît Aria qui vient
de faire l'objet d'un décret à la fin du
mois de janvier dernier ce plan
d'investissement va constituer une sorte
de vitrine de ce qui pourrait être
déployé à bien plus grande échelle sur
sur notre réseau ce plan
d'investissement que j'évoque comprend
deux nouveaux parkings de covoiturage
des voies réservées
covoiturage et transports en commun et
un certain nombre de pôles d'échanges
multimodaux à proximité des grandes
agglomérations deuxième axe que nous
avons engagé la mobilité des carbonées
avec l'accueil des véhicules électriques
sur le réseau vous avez fait allusion
tout à l'heure en fait nous sommes très
fiers d'avoir relevé le challenge qui
consistait à équiper 100% de nos aires
de service en station de bornes de
recharge très haute puissance et haute
puissance avant la fin de l'année 2022
ces choses faites depuis décembre
dernier
nous avons nos 97 terres de services qui
proposent à la clientèle entre 6 et 8
bornes de recharge très haute puissance
bon c'est un c'est un premier pas et il
faudra aller un peu plus loin je
reviendrai troisième axe le
développement du solaire sur notre
réseau
[Musique]
voyage en flux libre donc vous l'avez
indiqué nous avons mis en service au
mois de novembre dernier
la première autoroute en flux libre
intégrale la 79 entre Montmarault et
Digoin une autoroute que connaît
parfaitement le sénateur Genève
puisqu'il il est tout à fait concerné
par cette par cette autoroute
deuxième point grâce à notre nouveau
plan d'investissement que j'évoquais à
l'instant nous allons pouvoir équiper en
flux libre toutes les entrées du réseau
area donc c'est déjà une première étape
et donc vous le voyez la transformation
écologique de l'autoroute elle est déjà
elle est déjà en marche mais il faut
effectivement aller beaucoup plus loin
et personnellement je suis persuadé
qu'il y a nécessité de conclure avec
l'État
à court terme un très grand plan
d'investissement orienté transition
écologique un plan d'investissement qui
permettrait aussi en parallèle de
relancer l'économie et le secteur des
travaux publics qui en aura bien besoin
à la sortie de la crise actuelle ce plan
de transition écologique qui pourrait
comporter plusieurs milliards d'euros
d'investissement à l'échelle à l'échelle
de la profession je le vois bien
s'articuler autour de quatre points
premier point
le développement massif des nouvelles
mobilités des mobilités décarbonées
avec la vitrine que nous avons mis en
place dans le plan actuel deuxième point
important la reconfiguration complète de
nos aires de service pour substituer
progressivement
l'électrique au carburant donc pourquoi
parce qu'il s'agit de faire de mettre en
place sur nos airs non pas des stations
de bandes de recharge donc si ça huit
borne mais de passer à l'étape suivante
c'est à dire de créer de véritables
pôles de recharge entre 30 et 40 bornes
pourquoi parce que parce que c'est
absolument nécessaire si on veut
accompagner au plus vite la transition
qui est maintenant bien engagée du
véhicule thermique vers le véhicule
électrique
personnellement je l'intégrerai pas dans
ce dossier décarbonation les poids
lourds pourquoi parce que à ce stade je
pense que nous sommes pas mûrs il faut
il faut attendre un peu pour y voir plus
clair la technologie n'est pas arbitrée
à ce jour entre les caténaires les rails
dans les chaussées l'induction les
terminaux de rechargement tous les 300
ou 400 km sur le réseau autoroutier
européen il me semble prématuré de se
lancer à court terme dans cette dans
cette direction par contre il y a un
troisième point très important c'est
effectivement la généralisation du flux
libre sur l'ensemble du réseau
autoroutier c'est une difficulté de 79
c'est la première qui est en plus libre
et on peut comprendre que les clients
usagers soient un peu désemparés en tout
cas pour pour une partie d'entre eux j'y
reviendrai donc génération
généralisation libre qui permet
d'améliorer la sécurité de pouvoir
renaturer toutes les plateformes de
péage qu'elle soit grande barrière ou
petite gare et qui permet surtout de
réduire de manière significative les
émissions de CO2 qui sont créés par tous
les stopangos ou les ralentissements et
accélérations sur l'ensemble du réseau
je pense que ça représenterait quelques
centaines de milliers de tonnes
équivalent CO2 par an nous sommes en
train de effectuer le chiffrage fin au
niveau de la profession et ça peut être
significatif en terme de d'économie de
démission et j'ajoute aussi un quatrième
point qui qui vous concerne évidemment
en tant que représentant des territoires
c'est la construction de nouveaux
diffuseurs pour améliorer la desserte
nous avons une bonne dizaine de projets
au stade au stade des cartons mais qu'on
pourrait très bien ressortir si l'état
voulait bien nous aider à les financer
c'est aussi
la reprise possible de section ou de
bretelles à proximité de notre réseau
pour améliorer le patrimoine existant et
pour faciliter aussi
l'accès au réseau autoroutier
alors se pose la question de la
compensation de ce genre de
d'investissement massif bon je crois
qu'il faut se résoudre à une évidence
c'est que la compensation via
l'augmentation de tarif n'est plus n'est
plus efficace et les plus possibles
aujourd'hui pour deux raisons la
première c'est que
cette mesure de compensation et de moins
en moins efficace quand on se rapproche
de la concession pour pouvoir compenser
les investissements il faut avoir des
augmentations tarifaires très
importantes et deuxième point c'est que
l'acceptabilité du péage on la connaît
c'est très compliqué
nos clients nos usagers le grand public
ne comprend pas pourquoi nous avons des
augmentations tarifaires qui dépassent
l'inflation ou qui atteignent
l'inflation mais c'est parce que il y a
effectivement une composante qui est
liée à l'inflation 07 fois l'inflation
c'est la formule de base et si ajoute
des composantes des constantes qui sont
fonctions des programmes
d'investissement négociés entre les
concessionnaires et l'État et ce qui
explique effectivement les différences
de d'augmentation tarifaire entre telle
ou telle société ça dépend du programme
d'investissement qu'elles ont négocié
avec l'État
donc pour compenser un tel plan je
dirais qu'il y a pas de il y a pas il y
a pas beaucoup de solutions hormis
lallongement de la durée je sais que
c'est un sujet c'est un sujet compliqué
qui nécessite bien sûr à un accord un
accord politique qui nécessite un accord
de la Commission européenne et un accord
de conseil d'État mais pour moi ça reste
la seule la seule possibilité à ce jour
pour envisager un plan d'investissement
massif
pour ce qui concerne la rentabilité
alors je vais revenir encore une fois
sur le sur le thème c'est un sujet qui
revient à intervalles réguliers dans le
débat
je l'ai dit sur la base de rapport plus
ou moins a charge et sur des sur la base
de données fausses ou peu objective en
tout cas je veux redire très clairement
qu'il n'y a pas pour appairera de
surentabilité ou de surprofit comme on
peut le lire ou l'entendre et nous
sommes encore une fois afin 2022 très
proche des objectifs qui avaient été
affichés dans le plan d'affaires
communiquée à l'État dans le cadre de
l'appel d'offre de privatisation et je
pense que nous le serons aussi proches
de ce plan d'affaires en fin de
concession si on se base sur des
prévisions sérieuses qui sont
communiquées par nous chaque année à la
RT et au ministère des Transports
en tout cas nous sommes tout à fait
disposés à confronter les chiffres et
les modèles pour démontrer cette absence
de surentabilité et pour remettre les
pendules à l'heure si je puis dire alors
je dois tout de même saluer
une évolution de méthode dans les
derniers rapports
vers des calculs plus pertinents de
l'analyse de la profité des concessions
dans la mesure où on s'intéresse non
plus à la rentabilité instantanée comme
c'était le cas pour l'Autorité de la
concurrence en 2014 mais on va
maintenant regarder le taux de
rentabilité interne qui lui
effectivement analyse la rentabilité sur
la totalité de la concession donc on a
déjà on a déjà progressé mais après
reste à savoir de quoi on parle
et si possible avec des calculs juste et
les prévisions crédibles et je redis
encore une fois que je déplore que la RT
ne soit pas systématiquement placé au
coeur des débats sur ce sujet d'autant
que ça l'a fait clairement partie de ces
missions fixées par le législateur en
alors sur le terrible concession qui est
encore une fois la bonne mesure la bonne
référence de notre point de vue on peut
noter qu'il n'y a pas de difficulté tant
pour la RT que pour l'IGF
sur le terrier actionnaire
si on veut malgré tout le regarder il
faut partir sur de bonnes bases de
comparaison et il ne faut pas faire
d'erreur d'analyse et de méthodologie et
il faut faire des prévisions sérieuses
et surtout être extrêmement prudent
dans les conclusions car les choses
peuvent évoluer très vite dans un sens
ou dans un autre que ce soit au niveau
du trafic au niveau des taux d'intérêt
par exemple
concernant l'étude de monsieur Fortin
j'ai eu l'occasion d'alerter à plusieurs
reprises par écrit et par oral le
sénateur de la Haye sur les graves
erreurs méthodologiques et de
raisonnement figurant dans cette étude
que ce soit par exemple la comparaison
des flux de dividendes avec
l'investissement initial sans
actualisation l'affectation de
dividendes sur la base de la trésorerie
disponible et non pas sur la base du
résultat net comme la loi impose ou sur
l'ignorance des règles d'amortissement
qui sont spécifiques au concessionnaire
autoroutier
je ne reviens pas non plus sur
l'estimation des dividendes entre 2020
et 2022 que j'ai évoqué dans mon
préambule concernant le rapport de l'IGF
nous émettons aussi les plus grandes
réserves sur la fiabilité du rapport qui
s'inspire d'ailleurs fortement du modèle
financier de monsieur Fortin c'est écrit
dans le rapport et je dois vous dire que
c'est assez préoccupant en particulier
pour la prévision de dividendes poste
2019 d'ailleurs nous n'avons pas
connaissance du plan d'affaires de l'gf
nous n'avons pas connaissance de ce plan
d'affaires je rappelle tout de même le
contexte de ce rapport il a été rédigé
il y a je crois deux ans et demi
pour faire contrepoids au contentieux
engagé par par les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute face à
l'augmentation de la taxe d'aménagement
du territoire qui a été décidé une
allattéralement par le gouvernement fin
2019 dans le cadre du projet de loi
finance 2020
alors là aussi pour l'IGF je ne vais pas
entrer dans un débat trop technique mais
je vais tout de même vous donner un seul
exemple
le chiffre de 7,67% qui a été donné qui
est donné comme référence
du tri actionnaire il serait d'ailleurs
il est d'ailleurs commun en trois
groupes autoroutiers ce qui est entre
nous n'a pas vraiment de sens ce chiffre
ne correspond pas du tout à une
quelconque référence fixer ou convenu
entre les parties
je rappelle que en 2005 nos actionnaires
ont répondu à un appel d'offres
internationale et qu'ils ont répondu sur
la base d'un prix par action
et non pas sur la base d'un tri et avec
ce prix il était demandé par l'état de
justifier le prix par un plan d'affaires
qui a été communiqué et ce plan
d'affaires de ce plan d'affaires
découler un Terry de 9,3%. et non pas
7,67%. donc avant même de rentrer dans
les calculs et les prévisions il y a
déjà un sérieux problème sur la
référence et je répète qu'il faut être
extrêmement prudent avec les prévisions
d'autant qu'on connaît on ne connaîtra
qu'à la fin la rentabilité réelle de la
concession d'ici là le trafic les taux
d'intérêt peuvent évoluer très vite dans
un sens ou dans un autre et c'est
d'ailleurs le risque du concessionnaire
la prudence s'impose comme la justement
dit le ministre de l'Économie lors de
son audition à l'Assemblée nationale le
rapport dit même je le cite que c'est
conclusions reposent sur un calcul très
hypothétique et doivent être
interprétées avec une grande prudence
bon on peut regretter dans cette affaire
que la vie de la RT ne soit pas pris en
compte et on peut regarder aussi à tout
le moins qu'une phase contradictoire
n'est pas eu lieu avec nous pour éviter
des incohérences manifestent sur un
sujet qui est aussi sensible et aussi
polémique
alors sur sur la saisine du Conseil
d'État par le ministre de l'économie
bon le gouvernement est libre de se
tourner vers le vers le Conseil d'État
pour nourrir sa réflexion je crois que
c'est clair et il ne semble il ne me
semble pas que le gouvernement soit
entré en contentieux car il s'agit bien
d'un avis consultatif
les contrats ne prévois pas à ma
connaissance de stipule de stipulation
qui permettent une fin anticipée de la
concession sur la base du terrier
actionnaire même du théorie concession
ou sur la base d'une supposée sur
rentabilité bon ça va être en plus vrai
que la dite sur rentabilité est
injustement imaginée il y a en revanche
une clause je l'ai déjà dit qui a été
négociée dans le cadre de l'avenant du
plan de relance autoroutier 2015 qui
permet de réduire l'allongement de durée
qui a été
négocié et acté à l'époque c'est-à-dire
trois ans pour un PerR quatre ans pour
area dans l'hypothèse ou le chiffre
d'affaires cumulé de la concession
depuis l'origine dépasse un certain
seuil
ça existe effectivement
et puis je crois que dans cette affaire
il faut toujours garder à l'esprit que
la qualité de la signature de l'État est
extrêmement importante tout comme le
respect des contrats je crois qu'il y va
de la crédibilité de la France vis-à-vis
des investisseurs français ou étrangers
et je crois d'ailleurs que le ministre
de l'Économie la répété à plus de
reprise lors de son audition à
l'Assemblée nationale le 22 mars
question sur la question sur le
l'évolution des travaux
alors
la réglementation est très stricte
et
la création de la affaire en 2015 qui
est devenu dans l'intervalle la RT a eu
pour effet
d'offrir beaucoup plus de transparence
dans l'attribution des marchés mais pas
seulement car les marchés éligibles au
passage en commission des marchés ont
été réduits désormais ces 500 000 euros
en travaux 240000 euros pour les
fournitures et services par ailleurs
depuis cette époque depuis 2015 les
commissions des marchés comprennent un
nombre majoritaire de membres totalement
indépendants
et la DGCCRF participe à l'ensemble des
réunions
pour ce qui nous concerne apparaît à la
RT n'est pas critique sur le taux
d'attribution des marchés de travaux à
des entreprises du groupe Eiffage
d'ailleurs je peux vous donner quelques
chiffres pour vous permettre d'évaluer
la situation
sur les cinq dernières années
la commission des marchés a attribué
chaque année entre 20 et 25% des marchés
à des entreprises liées au groupe
Eiffage avec une moyenne de 25% sur les
cinq ans donc je pense qu'il y a pas de
vrais problèmes
vis-à-vis notre actionneur et Fages cela
correspond d'ailleurs à la part de
marché à peu près à la part de marché
que détenait Eiffage avant la
privatisation des autoroutes en tout cas
je peux vous dire que nous sommes
extrêmement vigilants dans les
commissions des marchés sur ces sujets
là
la transparence est totale les dossiers
sont épluchés à la loupe par la
déchetterie CCRF et par la RT si il y a
le moindre problème la RT peut stopper
l'attribution à la connaissance il n'y a
pas ce type de problème au sein de au
sein de notre groupe
sur la fin des contrats l'inventaire et
la classification des biens notamment
les biens de retour donc un sujet qui a
été évoqué par un certain nombre d'entre
vous je sais qu'il est cher au sénateur
Jacquin pour n'avoir discuté à plusieurs
reprises avec lui donc en tant que que
gestionnaire du patrimoine de l'État
nous tenons un jour l'inventaire des
biens pour tout vous dire c'est un
travail très long et très complexe
tellement le volume de données est
important c'est donner elles sont
répertoriées dans des bases de données
métier qui sont propres à notre société
mais le partage des données avec les
services du ministère des Transports est
en cours depuis de nombreuses années
bon il se trouve qu'en 2016
au vu du volume de données à recueillir
les services du ministère des Transports
ont décidé d'utiliser une nouvelle base
de données qui
qui peut traiter à la fois
le réseau routier national concédé et le
réseau routier national non concédé ça
peut ralentir un peu le processus
les choses les choses avancent
normalement
en fait nous définissons avec les
services du ministère la nomenclature
qui est souhaitée puis il nous
transmettent les fichiers à remplir les
ouvrages d'art les chaussées et on peut
dire que ce processus il est maintenant
parfaitement opérationnel et en tout cas
il n'y a aucune atticence de notre part
pour fournir les éléments que nous avons
déjà dans nos bases
pour la classification des biens donc il
faut distinguer effectivement les biens
de retour qui relèvent de la concession
et qui sont indispensables à son
fonctionnement les biens de reprise que
le Conseil dent peut
choisir de reprendre à son initiative et
les biens propres qui appartiennent pour
le coup au concessionnaire en fin de
concession bon pour des passionnés le
débat je vous dirais que plus de 95% des
biens sont des biens de retour vous le
retrouve notamment les les
infrastructures dans la très grande
majorité des actifs donc pour moi il n'y
a pas de il y a pas de difficulté sur
cette sur ce sujet bien de reprise bien
de retour bien propre tout devrait bien
se passer il y a pas de problème le vrai
sujet c'est pas celui-là le vrai sujet
c'est ce qui ce que signifie le bon état
d'entretien qui figure dans nos contrats
en fait
ce bon état d'entretien ce bon état
notre patrimoine il est il est déjà
assuré grâce aux indicateurs de
performance qui sont calculés et mis en
place depuis 2014
de nouveaux indicateurs patrimoine sont
inclus dans nos contrats au fur et à
mesure des avenants c'est le cas
d'ailleurs du dernier avenant qui inclut
à nouveau un nouvel indicateur sur la
sur les structures de chaussée cette
question devra être totalement tranchée
avant l'audit qui est prévu 7 ans avant
la fin de concession mais je peux vous
dire qu'on dispose déjà d'une d'une
cartographie précise des ouvrages et des
chaussées grâce aux indicateurs de
performance qui existent et qui et qui
vivent qui sont suivis chaque année par
nous et par le concédant donc je suis
plutôt confiant sur le fait que nous
trouverons un accord complet et
définitif avec l'État sur cette affaire
de bon état d'entretien afin de
concession dans les dans les prochaines
années
sur sur l'avenir des contrats question
m'a été posée
je crois sur comment on voit la viande
des contrats bon d'abord j'espère que
que je pense que nous serons parties
prenantes des assises de l'autoroute que
le ministre des Transports a indiqué
vouloir mettre en place à l'été prochain
et pour justement débattre de ce de ce
sujet
donc l'état décidera mais vous ne serez
pas surpris si je recommande de
poursuivre le modèle de la concession à
la française j'ai déjà évoqué tous les
avantages le transfert de l'intégralité
des risques concessionnaires des
savoir-faire reconnu et démontrer par
les concessionnaires privés une grande
capacité d'investissement
bon il faudra sans doute adapter les les
contrats en termes de contenu
probablement mettre
introduire une certaine dose de
régulation
des clauses de régulière de revoyure
pour suivre la rentabilité réelle et
l'adapter ses besoins alors non pas
parce qu'il y a un problème dans les
contrats actuels mais parce que cela
permettra d'éviter
les soupçons et les polémiques qui
reviennent à intervalles réguliers sur
le sujet je pense que ça sera préférable
pour tout le monde vous l'avez dit je
pense qu'effectivement on pourra
envisager de réduire les durées nous
sommes actuellement sur des durées de 30
ans
bon il faudra parler du retro trop trop
non plus parce que le les futurs
concessionnaires ont besoin d'avoir une
certaine visibilité pour organiser leur
outil pour pour préparer leurs
investissements et pour les amortir bon
aujourd'hui 30 ans pourquoi pas 20 à 25
ans dans les dans les futurs contrats
il faudra aussi peut-être revoir le
périmètre des concessions pour éviter
par exemple qu'un seul acteur puisse
gérer plus de 50% de l'ensemble ce qui
est ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui en
tout cas j'imagine mal un retour en
arrière et une reprise à 100% pour moi
la gestion des autoroutes ce n'est pas
une mission régalienne et le vrai sujet
c'est de trouver
la meilleure solution de gestion sous
forme d'une concession je dirais
retravaillée mais avec des acteurs
privés voilà voilà comment je comment je
vois les comment je vois les choses
j'ai encore quelques minutes monsieur le
Président alors quelques d'autres
questions qui ont été posées notamment
concernant le viaduc de Millau qui vous
est cher monsieur le sénateur
alors un petit rappel sur l'actionnariat
du viaduc de Millau depuis 2008 Eiffage
détient 51% la Caisse des dépôts est
consignations
49%, il y a eu effectivement un certain
nombre de rumeurs de des engagements
possibles non pas des phages mais de la
Caisse des dépôts
à ce jour je n'ai pas du tout de
confirmation sur une éventuelle volonté
de la Caisse des dépôts de sortir du
capital voilà ce que je peux ce que je
peux vous dire sur le sur le viaduc
concernant les véhicules autonomes est
connecté c'est un bon c'est un sujet
important
bon qui avance effectivement plus
lentement que ce que nous avions pu
imaginer il y a quelques il y a quelques
années bon néanmoins on continue à
continuer à travailler nous avons un
certain nombre d'accord de partenariats
avec avec des constructeurs ou avec
Valeo qui font passer régulièrement
notamment sur l'axe Paris Lyon ce genre
de véhicule pour les pour les tester bon
il reste quand même quelques difficultés
sur le plan technique vous avez dit que
sur l'autoroute c'était plus simple que
sur le réseau classique vous avez
entièrement raison néanmoins toutefois
c'est un peu plus compliqué notamment
lorsqu'on arrive en zone de travaux avec
des balisages des réductions de voix
tout n'est pas complètement réglé les
choses les choses avancent mais bon à
titre personnel je trouve effectivement
qu'il y a un certain ralentissement des
constructeurs sur ce projet qui
paraissait facile
ça passait facile d'aboutir à court
terme ce n'est visiblement pas le cas je
pense que maintenant on est plutôt sur
du sur du moyen terme que sur du court
terme mais rassurez-vous les tests se
poursuivent en particulier sur notre sur
notre réseau
alors sur les tarifs je voulais je
voulais indiquer nos contrats prévoient
une formule tarifaire qui est basée
essentiellement sur l'inflation mais qui
permet également de financer par des
constantes complémentaires des plans
d'investissement bon nous avons bien
conscience que les hausses qui ont été
pratiqués
au début de l'année sont importantes
dans un contexte difficile sur le plan
du pouvoir d'achat la moyenne des
augmentations pour les sociétés
historiques s'élèvent à
4,75%, ça reste néanmoins inférieure à
l'inflation qui était de l'ordre de 6% à
fin octobre bon cela étant nous avons
pris
la dimension du sujet et en lien avec le
ministre des Transports nous avons mis
en place
plutôt nous avons amélioré les formules
d'abonnement qui existent qui existaient
pour la clientèle fréquente la clientèle
domicile travaille depuis
2019 je crois nous avions attribué 30%
production pour cette clientèle
fréquente et le déclenchement de cet
abonnement est lié à un minimum de 10
allers-retours par mois sur un trajet
donné nous sommes passés de 30% à 40% à
l'occasion des hausses de début 2023 et
là aussi pour donner un coup de pouce à
la transition écologique nous avons mis
en place un nouvel abonnement pour les
véhicules électriques qui prévoit une
réduction de 5% sur l'ensemble des
réseaux autoroutiers
l'ensemble du réseau autoroutier en tout
cas sur l'ensemble du réseau à Pereira
alors bon un autre sur à 79
effectivement je le disais la difficulté
c'est que c'est la première autoroute
qui bénéficie de cette technologie je
vous rassure la très très grande
majorité de la clientèle est très
satisfaite de cette de cette innovation
bon la plupart des
usagers
l'empreinte avec un badge de télépéage
ce qui est extrêmement simple d'ailleurs
nous nous avons milité dans les
premières semaines pour que les
les les clients locaux puissent
s'équiper de ces badges c'était le cas
on a on a je pense réussi des campagnes
en début de en début de mise en service
nous avons aussi la possibilité de
d'abonnement plaque par l'intermédiaire
de l'abonnement internet pour ce qui
concerne les gens qui ne souhaiteraient
pas utiliser le badge qui ne
souhaiteraient pas utiliser la bande
plaque nous avons mis en place des
bornes de paiement des bornes à pied sur
l'ensemble des aires de repos
nous avons mis du personnel sur ces
herbes c'est bon à pied pour essayer de
de d'expliquer aux gens comment comment
on client en difficulté comment s'en
servir
je vous cache pas qu'il y a eu des
difficultés dans les premières semaines
les premiers mois cela étant
progressivement les choses s'améliorent
on va on est bien conscient du problème
donc on va encore renforcer la
communication on va renforcer la
pédagogie et on espère très sincèrement
que dans les prochains mois il y aura
plus de difficultés encore une fois ça
aurait été plus facile c'est tout le
réseau autoroutier était passé
massivement en flux libre là on est sur
un peu de titre tronçon de 90 km c'est
plus délicat mais la situation n'est pas
n'est pas excessivement difficile quand
même je sais qu'il y a eu un article
donc que choisir sur le sujet qui a fait
un peu boule de neige comme c'est un peu
l'habitude sur d'autres problèmes mais
bon on n'est pas on n'est pas très
inquiet ça va déjà beaucoup mieux
bien merci monsieur le Président merci
pour pour ces réponses à nos questions
je crois qu'effectivement il est bien un
moment donné de donner les explications
claires n'étaient précises pour éviter
ce que vous disiez tout de suite l'effet
boule de neige parce que on en voit une
une réflexion ici on l'a on la lance
elle retombe on sait pas où et puis
après on a une vraie certitude que c'est
exact et que ça marche pas ou que ça
fonctionne pas ou c'est pas comme ça
qu'il fallait mettre merci pour pour ces
réponses parce que ça nous permet aussi
à nous de d'avoir un éclairage à la fois
sur sur le devenir des concessions à la
fois sur et bien comment ces concessions
vont être vues et puis aussi quelque
chose qui est important parce que je
crois qu'il faut qu'on le
et il faut bien qu'on le prenne en
compte c'est la décarbonation et je
crois que ici autour de cette table tout
le monde est bien conscient que il y
aura des investissements lourds des
investissements importants pour la
décarbonation et que si on veut être au
rendez-vous et bien
le temps je dirais de des reproches des
polémiques ou autres n'est plus
d'actualité le temps est à l'action
merci merci
merci